I had a couple battle I can't repeat the
name it doesn't work and everything will
change
[Music]
be a patient hell the tricky what's good
everybody good morning good morning good
morning good morning here on Friday the
29th of May I missed all of you I hope
you missed it as much as I did
it's good to be back on tea with Gary
Vee Jenn Hassan thank you so much being
on Scott thank you for being on Peter
McDonald please leave your comments
right now facebook youtube twitter
linkedin where you're from I like I like
getting a sense twitch in the building
James Michael Poole oh great to see you
here thank you so much
Jorge Castillo us thank you so much
William Caden in the building
Garrett Glenn I'm trying to have my tick
tock off the chain hope everybody's
super super super well Dustin how are
you excellent missed you too
and it's really really really good to be
here awesome today's in me a good show
very good show I already know it I agree
I think today will be a very very good
show let's start it off cool
oh we're started off hot what's good
boat snowballs
how are you yachty ain't been asleep yet
is that a beautiful babe shirt yeah I
have to stay up for you because I the
album huh nah this is for you if I want
to sleep on when I made it I get that
but what about the album bro oh yeah man
I was midnight man that was it was
amazing it was how's that Hugh Jackman
great I can't wait to sit down and
listen to it today man it was great
getting some real love yeah and I am
genuinely pissed oh I love that
so what's been going on how you feeling
good bro you know um I recently bought a
house I'm moving to a new house next
Friday
thank you and what was the what was the
biggest process with this with this new
out of like what how did you think about
the project the hardest part was when I
had to strip songs you know I got
towards the end of the process and I had
too many you know and then just trying
to figure out what but why why are there
too many like well the record labels
like do they just like if you were like
now I really want all these on or is
that your own I just don't want to have
that many on this yeah I could do it if
I wanted to do with in a sense that I
want to have a 20-6 long out in 20 song
along why just don't feel like 26 I just
don't want to have a hour and 20 minute
album I get that I was an hour and 20
minutes of your voice well I mean your
stories know you have a number you can
call me
but what's up what's going on with your
tick-tock just going crazy I just
started a week ago I just started a week
ago
what uh what have I been telling you
yeah take a listen it's a huge
opportunity for you you have to have to
have to make sure that as much of the
music on the album is gonna be on
yeah like literally make a tick-tock for
like your favorite hook in ever or verse
it or bar in every in every song you
need to make a video around that clip
yeah 100% I'll show you over the weekend
you got any questions before we go to
sleep um no you're the man obviously and
I thought well no that and man you know
nothing to say what's the what's good
even new album on to make sure everybody
in the banner nation who's watching
right now Lobo 3 man's everywhere I'd
some Spotify title google play amazon
yeah I can't wait to listen to a bro
I love you thanks for saying it up a lot
of you some love this morning take care
I heard everybody that is lil yachty one
of the one of the funniest most creative
like such a deep thinker for a young man
real good kid makes me smile every time
I see him so it's good to see him that
was a it's a nice little nice little
start to this show all right let's get
right into it let's keep it going hey
how are you I'm great how are you
I'm super well real quick before we go
into this yeah a couple things everyone
today is the youngster show so we have a
ton of youngsters on today's show which
I'm really excited about Dustin am i
doing a good job with holding this up or
you like feeling happy about that yeah
sounds great so it's a youngsters show
today also I'm gonna be thanking random
people on the show today for entering
the the all in challenge so just a
really fun loving show we started off
with yadi his new albums out Lobo 3 make
sure you download that check it out
guarantee you're gonna love it there's a
couple Easter eggs for the vaynernation
in there on uh on a separate note
hashtag tea with Gary B I want to make
sure that everybody hits Twitter hard
right now with this hashtag I want to do
more of this because I want more
awareness for the show we want to do
more good vibes more positivity hashtag
tea with Gary Vee leave your favorite
quotes or you love favorite moments from
each guest today and I'll go and share
and retweet a bunch of you so there is
the hashtag vid what's cooking what are
you from what's your story
and I'm about to be a singer and pretty
much my issue is there's so many things
that I'm passionate about and that I
love but I get I'm an athlete I'm into
modeling I sell bracelets but I guess my
question is how do I make the right
decision I want to focus on or what to
pursue when can I can I give you great
news yeah whatever you pursue whether
it's all of them which is absolutely
feasible at this young of an age up
until you know you for the next 16 years
you've only been alive for 16 and for
the next 16 years if you just pursue all
three that would be smart because you'd
only be 32 and you'd have a sense of
your skill and your love for those three
things but let me tell it to you in a
better way here are some good news you
won't even know you won't even know if
one of them was the better decision
because that's not how life works
everyone's so crippled to make the right
decision when you'll never know there is
no time machines there is no preview
machines you just pick and go you go
with what you feel at the time it's more
about it's more about loving yourself
and being confident yourself you just
don't know you don't know yeah it's just
it's just hard because I'm so used to
having a plan like I'm so organized and
I like things laid out you know and I
know where I want to be but just like
which path do I take to get there it's
not I totally understand but like so lay
it out go bring out your journal and say
I'm in a model and retail and athlete
for the next three years then I'm gonna
pick one and go hard for three years
then I'm gonna make a decision at 22 if
I want to change it up people
I'm telling you life is fluid right you
I bet you in your planned out process
you didn't have a pandemic keeping you
in the house for six months right like
you know life life it's nice that you
have things planned out but you have to
start the process of being prepared for
when life takes turns yeah I just like
like there is no wrong there is no wrong
choice bit mm yeah but it's like what
how great the thing is there's more than
three things on my mind you know so do
those [ __ ]
things how do I know which ones a high
being which one is it which one's the
one you're not gonna know that's that's
what you got to get comfortable with
yeah it's it's it is damn it's good it's
actually good right now it's damn but if
you keep working on this Yuri watch this
video four thousand times you played in
your own head you figure it out for your
own way it's actually amazing because
then there's no wrong answer yeah
everyone's like I want the answer I'm
like no because then there's wrong
answers how about not having wrong
answers or answers and just living and
just aiming for happiness and if you and
if you pursue modeling for seven years
and then at 23 you're like nah and then
you want to sell coconuts go yeah you
see if you need to make sure that you
want the plan not your parents your
teachers society your coaches you know
what I mean they want plans cuz they you
know that's what most people play
defense but the the 30s and 40s and 50s
and 60 year olds that try to make 16
year-olds live life like they're 30 40
50 60 or doing a disservice yeah I just
I want to I want to be ahead of the game
you know I you are ahead of the game if
if you're on [ __ ] tee with Gary Vee
you're ahead of the [ __ ] game
I know I'm serious though so I know
honestly you are listen the way to be
ahead of the game is to be focused on
happiness not perceived societal success
on money or clout or or whatever else is
running through your head you want to
actually be let me teach you something
you'll never forget you want to be ahead
of the game
aim for [ __ ] happiness mm-hmm I'm I'm
happy every day like I you know I only
do what makes me happy but the thing
there's a lot of things make me happy
and I'm happy with a lot of things me me
too so basically you're talking about me
right now
not just compare yourself to me yes I
did listen
me stay in that zone that's good don't
let people talk you out of that and
saying you got to focus on something or
you got to be practical or you gotta get
real or you've got to figure it out at a
certain point cuz you're gonna be a
senior like it's crazy your [ __ ]
child
I know 60 year olds of that don't have a
[ __ ] idea about life yeah I just I
just feel like but I just want to make
the most of all my time you know let me
promise you the best way to make use of
your time by not dwelling about making
the most use of your time by not
overthinking not by not like debating by
not you know like that the way that make
most of your time is by doing [ __ ] yeah
so like I'm just a bad decision maker
though I'm not like not a bad decision
maker but I just I don't know how to
choose between certain things and what I
flip a [ __ ] coin yes I'm serious
you like them all you shouldn't be
crippled by having lots of interests
yeah yeah all right I'll try Gary I'll
do it for you I do believe in alright
have a great day man I love you back see
ya alright let's keep this going that
was fun how are you I'm doing well
what's been going on uh not much
just super excited to be here thanks for
you know doing this I'm happy to do it
tell me about yourself where you from
what do you do yeah so I La Colonia
first-generation just graduate from
Harvard last year I'm passionate about
real estate and cryptocurrency
well Harvard huh you want subtle on that
man that's a big get good for you and a
real [ __ ] student out here yeah yeah
yeah I'm just working hard you know yeah
school came very natural to you um I
yeah I was able to catch things pretty
well in school but I think a lot of it
just comes down to you know hard work I
don't think I was any more
you know intelligent than anybody else
in my classroom I just noticed that I
paid attention when other people wanted
to you know just goof around like I go I
goof I goofed around like [ __ ] crazy
actually I didn't goof around I would
have like bothered you if I sat next to
you trying to sell you some [ __ ] [ __ ] up
Gary I'm trying to get to Harvard so
what kind of kid were you like like did
you collect things were you just all
about the books sports musically how did
you hear um well I grew up from like I'm
like a low-income family so when I
started I was look like maybe I don't
know four or five and uh and my mom kind
of gave me these little like plush toys
to go and sell out to like the you know
to my neighbors and stuff so I wanted a
Nintendo DS so I I went out and I sold
you know those things sold like 200 of
them bought my PS um and I kind of just
kept that like work ethic going I for
high school yeah I really did have to
hit the books because I wanted to get
into Harvard because uh they have really
good financial aid systems and I didn't
want to pay for any of my college so
luckily I wasn't actually came out of
college with savings so yeah the Harvard
cosign and savings not just intense bro
I'm really proud of you that's epic
yeah questions yeah I do so I'm
preparing for basically I want to start
a company within maybe two or three
years I know I I just graduated college
so like I know I mean what's your social
media handles Jose in the flesh that's
my Instagram I don't really do tik-tok
but I should I should I know I should do
that based on what you saying you should
if you want the awareness and the
attention to deploy against your
nonprofit ventures your you know
political adventurers your social
ventures your business ventures and
building audience allows you to have a
voice and there today you might not care
about anything but in 16 years you might
or today you might be like well I don't
sell anything yet you want to raise
money to build a playground in your
neighborhood well guess what having four
hundred thousand followers on tick-tock
can do that I think people are estimate
what attentions value is ice
in the context of you know business so
much but there's so many reasons to you
know you know build an audience because
there's so much opportunity out there to
you know really do things yeah yeah go
ahead
yes so a question that I had is I'm
pretty sure for the initial year to that
like I start this company um it'll
probably be burning profit for the you
know a little while so what is the best
what is the most convincing kind of
prototype to minimize the risk for
investors because I know like I invest
my money and so like whenever I see or
like read a company's balance sheet or
any of their financial statements I want
to I want to see what the business is
working like so what is the most
condensing the problem is when you're an
idea phase you're just throwing numbers
on excel sheet to appease financial
people yeah it's some hard word [ __ ] ya
know like like to me you got a look at
it one of two ways one listen I talk a
lot about you know colleges are a why if
you go into debt being an issue you on
the flip side or the reverse poster
child you did it perfect in my opinion
to have a Harvard cosign and not have
financial debt Jesus you like to me
that's the you're kind of like the
bizarro like all the things I tell kids
are like hey if you're not good in
school start your business don't take on
debt learn work for free you play the
other side of the coin perfectly so you
got leverage you can go you can get
meetings cold by saying I went to
Harvard
did it it it it here's my business and
you can get meetings and show a 16-page
deck and you know what the answer is you
don't even need me for that affirmation
you just gotta show him a projection of
2020 for profit that blows me away that
people [ __ ] with [ __ ] like that cuz
that's on some guessing [ __ ] but you but
it works all day long or or you go to
somebody who's an entrepreneur and just
believes in you as a kid and just wants
to invest in you and they're a little
bit more loose more intuitive you know
you might be more analytical I'm more
emotional I invest in people based on
intuition yeah you know what I mean so
ya know tumblers balance she didn't look
good but I knew David Karp was a genius
and tumblr was gonna win and it did yeah
right and sold for a billion dollars you
know what I mean so
you know I think there's a lot of ways
to do it Jose okay doctor so my initial
round saw what I wanted to show
basically as a prototype was maybe by
simple duplex and for background the
company that I want to start is kind of
relating you know like real estate and
are you familiar with like smart
contracts so I kind of want to master
those two ideas to give you know tenants
more leverage and at the same time give
I got it so if you're saying you've
saved up enough money that you can go
execute an example it's game over okay
yeah yeah that's right well I'm saving
up money like that's partly why I'm
working on at this business yeah okay
cool
so that was my intro bro seeing it one
time is always better than reading about
it ten times yeah okay show people the
[ __ ] truth it's game over yeah I
invest in that kind of [ __ ] all day cuz
you're like Oh proof of concept yeah huh
hustler kid sold [ __ ] stuffed animals
gosh it has to Harvard for low income no
debt yeah [ __ ] I'll go with this dude
okay and then the other question that I
had was I'm obviously very new to all of
this and you know you hear horror
stories you know at Harvard about you
know who knows if Mark Zuckerberg
actually stole Facebook or not you never
know so like how do you protect your
ideas as your true I guess these are
commodity you just get out of your idea
yeah just gave your idea yeah bro you
just gave your idea to 20,000 people
just now and I think 400,000 are gonna
watch it you just thought you gave it
okay that [ __ ] that [ __ ] [ __ ]
story about sucks that's just [ __ ]
horseshit like you don't executions the
game yeah what Facebook was [ __ ]
myspace yeah myspace was Friendster
Winklevoss is talking out here like they
invented some [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out of
here okay its execution bro execution
okay gotcha bro I really appreciate you
uh I know we have a lot of mix of people
today I really appreciate you yeah
before you no no I just wanted to
appreciate you for donating for the
all-in challenge you know I think I
think you bought some raffle tickets for
my
my thing right yeah yeah I really
appreciate that it's like going to a
good cause and people are getting fed
you know yeah yeah of course yeah no I
also like goose stuff for like home aids
and different things he's like you know
you never know what you can learn
instead it's helpful you know so have
you ever won some [ __ ] no not from
omae's uh I said it's pretty crazy
though because there did win some [ __ ]
yeah yeah I mean I
nobody's been very clear with me over
the phone I'm guessing that's what's
happening but I don't know you're
guessing right Jose you [ __ ] won the
garyvee all-in challenge you are the
winner
that's a year-long [ __ ] event awesome
I'm super happy yeah I'm about to spend
the next [ __ ] year with you
[ __ ]
congratulations bro thank you so much
for entering congratulations for winning
you are the winner of the garyvee
experience for everybody who's just
joining if you don't know Jose stay on
here right now let's play the video -
what was the all-in challenge win I am
giving away the ultimate garyvee
experience so garage saleing and film
trash-talking a workout with me and mike
Vacanti $25,000 shopping spree at Wine
Library ultimate Jets experience guests
of my podcasts I'm gonna fly you to
three of my keynotes the ultimate
garyvee experience ya know
you ready I'm super excited like I don't
know you wanted to keep it short
what part of like show the whole thing
did you not understand does so much
[ __ ] choice [ __ ] you got a [ __ ]
turquoise [ __ ] tank top and you're
not playing the whole [ __ ] thing it's
casual Friday actually that's fine
hose it we'll play it at the end Jose
congratulations bro I'm looking forward
to the Jets game I don't you know you
got $25,000 with the wine coming your
way I don't know what you can do with
that you might have to flip that I'm
looking forward to the three times I see
you at the keynotes next year at
vaynermedia well I mean look
now you're really set when you come and
work at Vayner for the week I'll line up
seven to twelve investment meetings for
you we'll get your deck proper it's a
[ __ ] rap bro you [ __ ] one okay
thanks man you got
take care see ya I'll see you soon you
know the problem with her with somebody
so like calculated and [ __ ] epic as
Jose his reaction was like thank you
very much like like we need it
just I think we made a mistake I think
we need to pull it from this drawing
again we needed something to [ __ ] cry
I need a snot coming out of their mouth
you know like I need it like real [ __ ]
like Jose was like I appreciate that I
will execute on my winning you know I
think I would probably react the same
way though I just like like in shock
still like not knowing how to react
anyway all right so hey for everybody
here thank you so much for entering the
Olinger challenge we raised over a half
a million dollars or around a half a
million dollars on on my raffle alone
and then obviously thank you for all of
you we raised 2.3 million dollars on
tic-tock the other day let's keep
getting into the youngster show my vibes
are high now I'm feeling good let's get
this going
hello hey how are you my man what's your
name um you know say
Yemen fan effect where are you from in
fate um I'm from New Jersey
what part I'm pissing me very nice close
to where I grew up
awesome to meet you what's good yes so
um um I I I'm only like 11 years old so
I'm like really young as you always say
so I've done like a lot of things I've
done trading I've had my own drop
shipping businesses now that I've got
all those things but what I really want
to become is in an acting but I've I'm
really convinced that to become an actor
um you gotta be like in like the ones
like big cities like um I'm like Los
Angeles or like Orlando like those big
places but like I'm all doing here in
New Jersey and so and it's like really
hard to move - all the way all the way
across the country all the way there
so like what's some advice that you can
like help me with like how can I become
an actor without like going to what like
a big big big places so your youngster
so I don't know if you're gonna know all
these names but do you know who Bruce
Willis's um yeah I think so no don't
worry
Joe Piscopo I don't think so no Frank
Vincent no right so look the bottom line
is there's unlimited actors from New
Jersey you know who Meryl Streep is I
don't think so it's okay it's okay if
you know none of these Jason Alexander
from Seinfeld you know that dude um you
know I'm sure I'm not sure if I may be
good news don't worry you don't need to
you're only 11 you don't know you know
that makes sense to me but you know
Danny DeVito is or John Travolta oh yeah
good all of those people are from New
Jersey hmm
you're 11 so yeah
I mean do you want to act when you're 22
or do you want to act now I want act now
what do you think your parents are gonna
let you go to New York and do auditions
yeah yeah well good news you don't need
to go to [ __ ] Orlando yes good we got
this you just got to get your parents to
drive you to New York and do auditions
literally Google auditions in New York
for acting right yeah and go try out
when here's a good part even if you
stink at it now if you work at it for 11
years which is how long you've been
alive at 22 you can go to LA and you can
try out for the next 10 years and then
ready for this cuz it doesn't feel like
this at 11 if you do that for 10 years
you'll still be young at 32 you might
get your app can break at 33 and since
you have this entrepreneurial hustle
that's already in you you'll probably be
able to maintain your lifestyle while
you keep going out for acting you'll be
able to do side hustles to pay your rent
and eat and if this is really your dream
and this is really in your soul then you
just go yeah yeah well thanks thanks
thank you you're welcome does that make
sense to you yeah yeah like do you like
do you understand that being in jerseys
are great but being in New Jersey is a
lot better than being in a lot of places
because your moments I mean your
Piscataway you're 35 40 minutes away
from New York City the epicenter of the
world hello thank you you're welcome
Jersey's better than Orlando for acting
yeah thank you you're welcome have a
great day you do thank you you got it
Dustin is your chat working length my
paws I love the chat seems to be working
absolutely all right keep going
Joe Piscopo I kid knew zero this is what
happens at 11:00
yeah you know they don't know any of
these people that's what happens yeah I
don't blame either let's keep it moving
Alex rotated hey guy I'm so excited to
finally talk to you thank you brother
how are you where you from I'm from
Mexico and I'm 17 what's good yeah so
basically I'm really into business like
my goal is to build a company and you
know my dream is to live in Silicon
Valley you know work 16 hours a day
coding just you know working then
customer acquisition then marketing and
right now like I'm debating because I
last year started doing Amazon FBA you
know to like have experience and you
know get some money but it all kind of
got stuck because of Corona yeah and
like last December I started um tik-tok
thanks to you I listened to one of your
podcasts and it was the first time I've
heard it from you so literally the first
day I heard it I downloaded the app I
made a video it was about books I've
I've read and like what are the lessons
but it didn't work and I started
consuming more on the platform then
making actually like contents native to
a platform when you said it wasn't
working how many pieces did you post
like 10 but it didn't work because I
posted in English and I didn't know
texture was region-locked
so basically not a lot of people
understood it but now I changed it and
now I'm not
point seven million followers all thanks
to you I'm glad I'm glad I took your
advice so my question is how first of
all I'm debating whether I should go
I mean do college because I'm always
into learning and I know it helps you be
a better person of course learning is
amazing how you pay for learning is what
I want to do yeah and I know I've been
really good at school but it was not I
just realized it was because I'm really
competitive not because I particularly
liked school now that I think about it I
didn't really liked it it's just that I
wanted you know to get better grades
than my book and you know I like to
study computer science you know biotech
and nanotechnology and I would like to
talk to you about AI you know boys
influencer at scale and ER but that will
have to wait I think all of that stuff
is coming as you know that's why you
brought it up and you've obviously been
listening so I appreciate that all of
its coming all of its coming I would
tell you learning how to develop on top
of a Lex and Google home invoice for
this young for this young of an age is a
huge opportunity yeah yeah but so my
question is should I go to college or
should I focus right now just on social
because I really like business remind me
how it would be in in Mexico like do you
pay for college or no yes but I would
like to road in you to a college in the
US I mean my dream is to go to Stanford
what I would like would you have to
collect debt to go to Stanford yeah I
think so
well maybe I can you know say hustle you
know leverage my tik-tok for more for
sure yeah Stanford is one of those few
schools that I think still has the
leverage with brand name and the caliber
of people walking around on campus I
think it's definitely one that I I'm not
against that if you can get there you
know yeah but that's the poem see like I
know I could get there but I will like
have to focus all my time on it I will
have time for anything else you know I
wouldn't have time to learn those skills
that I've learned on ticked up that's
what I also started you know
communicating my ideas leading you know
content producing all of that and also
it's hard for me to tell you if you
should or you shouldn't what I would
tell you is I kind of think you're gonna
win either way
to be frank like if you ask me the truth
of what I'm thinking right now I'm
thinking well this kid's gonna win
anyway so it's almost like which one do
you want more you know I really think
about college because of the
environments actually you know like
changing your environment
so yes you can but your connections but
you can you can go to you can go
somewhere else without college unless
you're saying with immigration laws and
things of that nature that college is
the way you can get in you know if you
want it you know that that would make
sense to me you know like you know I
don't know if you're able to get into
the u.s. without college and just go to
San Francisco and hang out in coffee
shops that would be my recommendation
but but if there is no way to do that
I'm just not educated enough on where
you know immigration laws are more
importantly if you have family in the
u.s. things of that nature but you know
if your way in is college then I think
that's a worthwhile thought okay and
last thing is that you know how can I
can i leverage like all the things I've
learned and say you know I've been
posting a lot of LinkedIn on how to
build your social media what I have
learned and I also help people which
have contacted me on how to build their
tick-tock and you know I didn't charge
them I didn't charge them my time in the
beginning now line uh-huh now MLM yeah
but I don't get that much like I know
like you know how to monetize because on
LinkedIn it's a whole different audience
I post on English which I cannot
leverage and i taked okay now I know
going for the ask is like the Chairman
saw oh it's no it's not always I would
tell you no remember
Jab Jab right hook Gib Gib Gibby I'm not
scared to ask people right now to sign
up for wine text watch this Alex sign up
for wine text today's an insane $40
white wine that's gonna be $18 and
change right there I want every single
person to sign up for wine text Dustin
everybody who signs up for wine text
make sure you throw them on the bottom
screen right now if they just signed up
and don't why lying is the devil
the Carmo will be horrible for you so
you know I think you can go in for the
ask Alex if you make a tick-tock right
now saying hey I've been able to grow my
tick-tock you know I'm thinking about
doing some consulting if you're
interested message me on tick-tock all
in Spanish and there's people willing to
pay you I think that's fine yeah you
know because the CPM on Mexico's it's
slow and you know getting brand deals
it's harder and thanks to Corona it's
even harder so I was also thinking like
you know producing content on English I
started new accounts but it didn't work
out because you know it's too
complicated to reach other regions and
all of that you know I think I think
switching back and forth between English
and Spanish on your 1.7 is not a bad
idea the English will do worse but over
time it will build and then some content
can be in Spanglish
I always tell a lot of my Spanish being
friends make one account some of its in
Spanish son of it's in English some of
its in Spanglish I mean you might be the
way people learn how to speak English
that want to that speak Spanish you you
know there's a lot I mean there's
unlimited people that speak both
languages and you have to be
let's go wall star finally and if you as
long as you don't worry about the the
metrics and you're okay with your
Spanish content getting you know 800,000
views or views it just froze my first I
can hear you okay me yeah no don't worry
that the English content is not gonna be
doing as well thank you extended family
don't worry the English content will do
as well yeah I'm not worried about that
but I'm just worried that it won't like
even reach all the regions because of
the region lock and you know it's really
comforting you don't control that bro
yeah
you can't cry about [ __ ] that you don't
control yeah
period
so do you think going for the ask that
like it's better on tip-toe credit on
LinkedIn or stuff like that oh no
well I'm sorry Nicole both oh okay both
keep moving out you're gonna win don't
you know the exact s bro I feel real
good about your vibes talk to you soon
let's keep movin it my youngsters Dustin
I'm not getting comments a lot of
comments so please throw up a bunch
during the episode because I live off
that [ __ ] Roger thank you
hi Gary how are you bro good what's good
with you
not much so I was wondering if our
parents don't approve of like social
medias like take talking Instagram how
can we convince them that it can be a
great thing
if our parents don't approve of like
social media
how come you convince them that it can
be a great thing for like fine meeting
new friends and if we have a business we
can promote our business you know
commencing parents when you're a kid is
super hard yeah you know I think one of
the ways to do that is results like take
that bowling ball pin and sell it for
$40 on tik-tok and then show them that
and all of a sudden they may take it
more serious you know why why do your
parents demonize social they think it's
a good it's a waste of time they think
you know I think mostly they think it's
a waste of time but they let me have it
I kind of convinced them but you know a
lot of my friends I know they want
social media but their parents won't let
them look parents normally parent with
fear so they're worried their kid's
gonna get in trouble see something they
don't want to get impressed by somebody
bad the reality is it that's a that's a
historic game that's not tea with Gary
B's gonna answer this question meaning
it's it's crazy Michael how that is like
that that's been the story of time your
parents tried to convince their parents
that playing video games or listening to
rock albums was a good idea and your
grandparents are trying to convince your
great grandparents that listening to
Elvis and the Beatles was a good like
it's all the same [ __ ] do you know what
I mean yeah the reality is is that all
you can do is try to find the balance of
you know really really really Thank You
Dustin for putting up Anthony Conte hey
Conte when you could explain to me what
[ __ ] I'm selling we can have that
talk you know you know I really think
that you just have to balance the the
family dynamic with trying to do a
little bit of your own when they're
quote-unquote not watching and and and
number two try to show a positive result
from it so that a quote unquote changes
your parents mind but but half the
parents in the world never change their
mind and are so selfish
about how they see the world they don't
become selfless enough to help their
children fulfill the way they see the
world yeah that's kind of what I'm doing
right now I love that you you watch my
content yeah I do you like it yeah
you're showing up on take talk a lot
more now try and bro hustling out here
what what what part of the content most
resonates for you Michael uh I try to
make like funny content I like that are
you part of the us crush gang yeah it's
good bro bro just keep going I think
parents is always a tricky game but
always remember eventually you're moving
out of the house and you got to live for
your happiness
without being disrespectful to parents
that's what I tell your buddies you know
yeah they you know they they're
eventually they're not gonna live there
and they're gonna have to live the next
80 years of their life on their own and
they have to find a balance of doing
what they want while respecting an F and
being it it's hard for a 15 13 12 year
old to be empathetic to their parents
but parents are always doing that [ __ ]
because they're scared yeah so try to
unscared them okay cool
talk to you soon thanks of course
Michael Dustin get that guy who called
me a [ __ ] artist on the show like
I'd like him to articulate in detail my
[ __ ] that would be interesting yeah
I I've had so many of those
conversations in my life like people
come into my office I've done a lot of
weird stuff like that and just the [ __ ]
that people make up they're like your
sellout like what am i selling top of
this sells something but at $0.00
you're giving people too much hope
literally this is what one guy told me
Dustin Kerry you're you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] artist cuz you're giving people
[ __ ] false hope I'm like bro don't
take your cynicism on the world and
[ __ ] deploy I'm just keeping it real
I'm like you're keeping it real [ __ ]
sad and dark keeping it real [ __ ] you
there's unlimited opportunity
[ __ ] yeah let's keep it going
you're on mute Cosman Cosman you're on
you mute hi how are you inside what's
your name
I'm cosmic husband are you from I'm from
Italy I think you remember you what's
good I'm just I'm doing it for them
Cosmo now what what's cooking what can I
answer for you
so my question comes from an interview
you did with Joe in Java if you remember
about artists and you said there should
be a balance of both selling your work
like your own work and working for
others but how do you get to a place
where you only have to sell your work so
we don't work on fire and stuff how do
you get to a place where what brother
wait you can only sell your work like
you always have
I mean there's a lot of people who never
get there it's called talent and hard
work you know what I mean yeah yeah
Anthony doesn't put on Anthony
um Cosman it you've got a you've got a
UH
you've got to put in hard work and
you've got to um you know get to a place
with uh you know get to a place where
you work hard and there's a demand for
your your uh your stuff so it's like a
more of an Banting than like that and
like it's more of building your own band
and of course of course you know
simple as that yeah you can i I see it
Dustin I see I see the anger the
negativity you can get them in here you
don't need to flash it anymore dust yeah
cuz you know it's really it's really
it's really just hard work and brand
building and you know then it comes to
you mhm
got it yeah yeah I was thinking about
like I'm not yet on tick-tock
but maybe start posting there and I have
been showing it blasted of course you
know the answers I'm putting it out
every day yeah it's awesome
keep pushing cause talk to you soon you
got it
how are you good and I've been golfing
for like 11 years now and my goal was
originally need to make varsity for my
high school freshman year which I did
that this year congratulations thank you
but now I want to like take it further
and play for like a d1 college which I
know you're not like the biggest fan of
college Don listen Kenzi real quick and
I'll use this opportunity I'm a huge fan
of college for people that don't go into
massive debt and then in four years have
a diploma that doesn't give them
leverage in the new workforce and then
you know I get hundreds of thousands of
emails and DMS and new messages from
kids that are really bad shape because
they were sold a dream that doesn't have
a reality if you go to any one school
and get a scholarship I'm all about that
life right yeah that's the goal that's
the dream so what I'm really wondering
is I know I'm not there yet like skill
level and I'm working to get there along
with like my grades but I was wondering
if you had any like suggestions for my
next step or like how to get noticed in
the future I mean I think you put out
content right like like I know you know
because I'm in Vayner sports
tons of kids are going to d1 football
colleges from small towns that would
have never been discovered because
they're putting up their highlights on
Twitter on YouTube on Facebook on
Instagram you should put out your golf
highlights everywhere right you know
there's gonna be a d1 you know you know
coach that's gonna see it and be like yo
go check on that Kenzie girl in Michigan
right yeah that's how I need to bring
them cause the last their last call it's
all about getting awareness right so for
doing that
would you suggest like making like its
own account like just for golf or you
could you are I like normal but you may
not want to do that with your social
life and I would understand that right
you know yeah just because like with
school I know I shouldn't really care
but it is hard sometimes a lot of people
will hate because I do golf and they'll
say it's like not a sport
yeah I mean honestly like you I'd prefer
you now you make me want to tell you to
put it into your regular account because
the question you get over the hump of
giving a [ __ ] when the cute guy says
it's not a scorn you're sad the quicker
you like the girl you want to be friends
with like you know what I mean like the
quicker you get over that hump the
happier your whole life will be right
for sure for real yeah for real kids
yeah I do put I have like a highlight on
my Instagram with all my golf stuff and
I you need to put out a lot of contract
maybe use Twitter for that right are you
active on Twitter I'm not I don't have
good perfect so get a Twitter and go ham
on there because that's where a lot of a
lot of coaches recruit from that
platform okay awesome yeah it was
awesome thank you so much take care you
two kids
it's good hey Gary yo I'm so grateful
Amir I'm doing too well
what's cooking what's your question so
basically my name is Kai I'm 15 years
old and from South Africa and I've had
quite a unique upbringing and around the
age of 8 my parents decided to sell
their selves their cause rents out the
house and go on a sort of like spiritual
journey traveling around the world for a
couple years and this really sparked a
huge interest for me in entrepreneurship
because I would visit so many you know
villages and different cultures in so
many countries and I would always notice
you know how different everything was
where you go and how the culture of
selling and buying and negotiating is
you know completed completely varies
where we are and I mean from the
youngest age like you know in India for
example I would I would go to the beach
at 8 years old and I would you know
volunteered these restaurants I would
learn how to do magic magic tricks and
I'll do it on the beach the tourists get
as many tips as I can save it all you
know everything when I was in Bali I
would get my hands on anything I've
heard that the cheap markets and then go
to the more upper-class ones and sell it
there and yeah so I mean when I got back
to South Africa for high school you know
my time and my I kind of you know I've
been focusing more on that and actually
yeah I competed in my country it's
called the Alan gray entrepreneurship
challenge so in 2018 I came in the top
20 in South Africa in a six-week
competition and then the next year
actually managed to get the top three so
I won yeah one it was an international
trip deuce to Marina Bay and Singapore
for tech conference it was gonna happen
this young 48 got postponed but I mean
yeah it was really cool so I mean I've
my whole life I've been absolutely
obsessed with everything to do with it
and I really really love you and I mean
about five six months ago I started
really pushing on tik-tok you know but I
mean I know it's not a lot but from
adults about a hundred and forty
thousand followers on this it's and it's
all because of you so I don't really I'm
very grateful you executed
I told to do it you executed
Thank You Man appreciate so I mean my
ultimate question um would be you know
how do I take this you know huge passion
that I have for business and combine
that with an online presence my
communicator you you I don't think you
realize you've already your bro you're
15 you said yeah bro you already have a
real audience on tick-tock just keep
making okay you've already done it the
ultimate question that you had for me
you've already executed yeah I mean yeah
okay you see where I'm going like you
know yeah you read 140 now when you're
when you're old as [ __ ] like me I'm
young by the way when you're four yeah
or that number is gonna be enormous bro
no listen to me you're gonna live two
more full lifes from the day you were
born to right now you're gonna do that
two more times and you'll be my age
think about a time you have yeah okay
understand cuz I mean like what I was
also thinking the Oscars because like
rod Nam in high school you know and like
there's a lot of stress like a lot of
family you know pushing on but like I'm
not particularly enjoying it that much
like I do put a lot of effort in sir but
who you know touching you
you I hear like all my grand yeah well
tell you grandpa hurts your [ __ ]
parents flew around the [ __ ] world on
a whim how the [ __ ] were you supposed to
give a [ __ ] about school tell your
grandpa to talk to their [ __ ] kids
they [ __ ] up you around the [ __ ]
world and [ __ ] it what the [ __ ] are you
you were [ __ ] on the beach in India
when you were eight how the [ __ ] do you
you know come on I mean I'm not grab my
whole family is actually also from they
Jews from the Soviet Union so they a lot
of them are like very you know you know
how it is but of course I do
yeah so I mean I guess my other question
would be you know considering my
personal situation what do you think is
the most promising industry to go into
you know in the next three to five years
like what should I kiss you social
cannabis cryptocurrency blah you know a
blockchain voice bro a million things
bro you look all the right mind said you
have all the right ingredients your
[ __ ] said don't beat yourself up stay
patient
nice and kind don't there's my friend
listen to me there's two ways to build a
biggest building Kai one just build the
biggest building to tear down everybody
else's building be the first one don't
worry about other people's success it
doesn't come from you stay patient stay
humble work you've got all the [ __ ]
ingredients you're well on your way
thank you so much man means a whole lot
I'd love to keep in contact with you
soon all right let's get some more in
here Carrie what's up good Rachel so
quick little story I'm from Brooklyn New
York love at 19 years old I'm gonna be
starting college this fall Congrats and
essentially a youtuber and I've built up
a small audience of almost 7,000 on
there but my thing that I struggle with
is there are times where I'm like super
consistent with my content posting every
week and there are times where I go to
like two weeks without posting and is
because every time yes every time I put
my focus into the video I want it to be
as you know good as possible so my
question is essentially how do I like
overcome perfectionism by forcing
yourself to do things that are
uncomfortable so what I mean by that is
the next time you see a video and you're
like no I got to keep working on this
remember this moment and just post it
because one of those videos is gonna do
better than all the other ones that you
perfected and then that will teach you
the [ __ ] lesson you're right you're
right but there are even like times like
where I'm in that mindset right and then
it just I post the video and then it's
like oh man it could have been better or
you know maybe I should have waited a
little more and worked on this thought
that that's because you're beating
yourself up perfection is hiding
insecurity that's true right yeah you
just have to practice it's like working
out it's like eating like Carrie how do
I eat better so I get healthier eat
better Wow
fight your head and get into a place
where you just do
yeah the fact that you're even asking
the question means that you're the
subconscious of it has become conscious
and now you have a real shot yeah yeah
no I have you know people constantly
asking the uploading or upload more and
it's like I don't want to and whenever I
I don't I feel like I disappointed
people you know listen you need to worry
about yourself go into your own place
but you need to love yourself you're
right you know I'm just telling you like
if people are asking you upload more you
know people enjoy it but more
importantly you need to enjoy the
process not the subscribers or the views
ya know I do I love the process like I
wouldn't trade it for anything
well then great so then put out more
[ __ ] all right I will
I believe I was gonna do it thank you I
couldn't shake company on your horse we
thank you quietly yeah of course take
care of Rachel YouTube right there for
everybody let's keep it moving let's
take a couple more kids in fun show
yo Gary what's good Noah was good uh so
story I am a fifteen year old for my
smallest town in Ohio I love it like the
small it's very southern right miss
Virginia so yeah I wanna be a youtuber
okay so like cuz I like I've been
posting on take talk but like it's just
not going anywhere over tick-tock so is
that like bad but no it's not bad but
good news know it youtubes even harder
to grow than tick-tock yeah but um so I
got my voice how many how many posts on
tick-tock I have like thirty right now
okay keep going
um so I guess my question is uh is it
okay to target like two audiences that
one's gonna do like gaming and blogs so
I can do that yes sorry
100% alright cuz I see like other things
like you should only go after one
audience no but I didn't know no people
say that because they want you to win
the short-term game you may get more
subscribers and views if you don't
target one but you're [ __ ] 15 and you
need to figure out who you are and what
you like and I'd rather you learn that
and have half as many followers and
subscribers and you still might have
more subscribers people are people play
checkers I'm trying to play chess out
here with you Noah
you're 15 we're just starting I want you
to do an entire account just on your
[ __ ] dimples it's your biggest
strength I got him to bit I know yeah
bro like like just do a whole make all
your tech talk about your [ __ ]
dimples take make ten [ __ ] tic TOCs
about your dimples all right oh well I'm
serious all right and when all your
buddies like that's corny tell the cup
[ __ ] come to me I'm gonna punch him
in the [ __ ] face no good bro
I'll come showing this shame all right
other than that do you just have any
advice for like a starting youtuber yeah
- just [ __ ] make and not look at
numbers numbers will [ __ ] you up
mm-hmm same would ticked up bro I want
you to make much more tick-tock just do
random different [ __ ] and look at
trending topics and hashtags and try to
make your version of that all right
got it yeah I want you to lean into
tick-tock it's it's
more free awareness than YouTube yeah
yep thank you yeah talk to you soon
see ya let's keep this going with sneak
another one in hi Gary
hi Briana uh I'm decided fun starts I'm
really excited to be here it's like
awesome opportunity so just want to
thank you for that first you're welcome
so 17 I'm from Long Island New York so -
and background before I go into my
question so I have a passion med
gazelles over the course of my life many
passions I mean sorry but two specific
ones being film and forth and I've
always dreamed of possibly going into
either industry whether it be a film
editor or in sports a GM or financial
advisor or sports writer anything like
that I never allowed myself to go after
any of those dreams because I've always
worried about job and financial security
from a really young age so I was always
worried like if I followed these
passions like I would risk like this
dream lifestyle I have which is like you
know a comfortable lifestyle you know
making enough money to be comfortable so
so she was being a girl in the sports
industry I felt like you know would be
too hard to get a good job I'm good
money so instead like I really focused
on school and discovering jobs that you
know where I would be you know a secure
job and make good money but um this past
summer I took a sports statistics course
and all I did was relation channel of
course itself through various field
trips to like you know sports places and
stuff like that I figured I really do
you want to go into this industry as
like a manager right or anything I can
so I feel like I can't follow my dreams
I still have those old fears and job and
financial security now so my question
why did your parents and still that like
be safe have a roof over your head or
was that just in your natural DNA I
think it's more natural these my parents
are really supportive of anything really
want to do um yeah my mom has always
been like you know follow your dreams or
think so oh and listen to me wouldn't it
be like if I said to you hey imagine
living with your best friends all the
time is that's that's good that's like
fun yeah
so let me let me explain this to you if
you follow your dreams you'll have to
live with like three of your best
girlfriends or boyfriends in one house
and eat like ramen and like [ __ ] live
that life that's more fun yeah it's more
fun to try to be on MSG and B or to be a
general manager or something it's like
more fun it makes you happier like you
can worry about a [ __ ] roof over your
head and a white picket fence and a
[ __ ] nice car when you're 37 mmm
you're [ __ ] 17 like the next seven
years you can go follow your dream this
is the time to actually be risky not be
safe hmm okay yeah I just doesn't make
like that's a lot like you're being
logical which I loved
so be logical in your twenties is when
you can take risk in your time like to
me it's more like I think it's more fun
to try to be on SNY and live in like
Queens with four of your friends in a
shitty spot and going out at night and
having fun and following all your dreams
than it is for you to have some secure
job and take a 40-minute train ride into
the city from [ __ ] Long Island on
some [ __ ] townhouse hmm yeah yeah
you're a hundred percent it's just you
know I've always had these fears I guess
they're also holding me back in a way in
a way they're completely [ __ ] holding
you back from being happy and when he
was scared up let's talk about it like
what you scared of you scared of like
living in a shitty place like like I
don't I don't get it I mean yeah I mean
I was fortunate enough to you know I'm
living in Long Island and then in a
great town too so I'm I'm used to splice
value and I don't that's not something I
want to lose either because I think I
got so comfortable I don't like you I
don't think you realize how little you
want that lifestyle you haven't tasted
the alternative when you live in a
[ __ ] with your buddies when you're
in your 20s but you're living your best
life because you're going after your
[ __ ] dream that's gonna taste a lot
better than a big room and a nice
[ __ ] yard mm-hmm yeah you're right
I'm also just not sure the guy's a girl
especially if just how to even get into
this industry when you know that there's
no there's more
half of the sportscasters have like
there's so many women in sports I mean
like manage manicure your position so
like don't you think like I'm managing a
team yeah something like that you know
and that's that that that's less there's
coaches starting to emerge
you know there's NFL coach yeah yeah
we're starting to see it and by the time
you're 34 when you'd be realistic
there's probably gonna be a lot more
he's not 1965 anymore there's unlimited
women in sport here yeah Plus once you
going for management you might realize
you want to be a scout and there's
unlimited women in scout you might
realize you want to be a journalist for
it there's unlimited you might decide
you want a sort of social media company
to represent athletes you might want to
compete with Vayner sports you don't
know yet yeah
but don't take some [ __ ] job because
you want to [ __ ] bush outside you're
apart
yeah yeah you're not as accustomed to
your cush as you think okay that you're
not I have to get comfortable with fear
okay yeah okay it's more fun it's more
fun it will you will like it more and by
the way my prescription for you is to
actually live in a shitty situation I
want you to live in the hood in Queens
like I'm serious okay because then
you'll know you can mmm you have to make
yourself uncomfortable yeah okay
understand good thank you so much you
won't get so much Briana take care bye
bye Thank You meryt everybody thank you
so much for watching the show big wine
texts today thank you for all the kids
how many kids do we have in the queue
dust - alright well sneak them in next
week thank you it's good to be back on
the t show let's uh let's leave some
hash tag tea with Gary Vee thoughts on
today's show please on Twitter so I can
watch in my next boring meeting it's not
boring but its operational and I love
you guys a little bit youngsters I love
to hate
in today's episode as well and big shout
out to boat yachties new album has
dropped please check it out and honestly
if you need some white wine today's is a
banger a banger we'll see you next time
on tea with Gary Vee check out my new
Twitter my new Twitter handle Gary BTB
it is exploding sign up right now here's
why you should the people that are gonna
win over the next five to seven years
are gonna be very comfortable and
controlled the process requires
sacrifice all your actions have to get
mapped back back back back back back
nobody gives a [ __ ] about where you grew
up the whole game is scaling the
unscalable it's [ __ ] hard work it's
being respectful it's being a good
person who that that's just a good idea
it's there the flip things there this
house right here there's 400 dollars to
do I stay milady
like real [ __ ] tight but you can't be
crippled everybody here's judging
themselves you're looking at what's in
front of you right now
you're losing because you're laying in
your bed looking at somebody's [ __ ]
glamorous photoshopped picture of them
doing something cool and you're envious
and you're jealous and you're impatient
and it's crippling you're up side let me
just say one more time if you're
confused what I just said I say put your
[ __ ] flag on the ground up who the
[ __ ] you are whoever provides the most
value always you're entering the
greatest five year window of your life
my only answer today or any much like
it's just like try [ __ ] don't your
business down and go work for an apparel
company behaviour nobody you've ever met
got there without the hard work so you
better get your speed up you better work
harder you better work smarter Google
stuff you're not gonna be able to do
anything that I'm telling
like hell to check me out hope you enjoy